so what happens if you continually lose
status
really bad things you know what one of
the when i was thinking about you know
in the very very early stages of
thinking about whether even this could
be a book i i kind of set myself a
little task and that was the task or
question really you know if you're going
to argue that status is important it
must be really bad when we lose it so so
what does that look like and so i
started to research humiliation the
effects of humiliation and and that's
what really convinced me because so so
the the definition that i came across of
humiliation is it's it's not just um
somebody taking your status away from
you it it's basically robbing you of any
hope of claiming that status again in
the future you're so lacking in status
you're basically banned from the game
and and you know one psychologist
describes the humiliation as the nuclear
bomb of the emotions so when you look at
the very worst things that human be
beings engage in from anything from
genocide to honor killings to spree
killings um to you know many instances
of serial murder um it has humiliation
at its core
so
so you know
that that really convinced me that
this was a really important subject and
that status was you know a fundamental
human need in the book i tell you in
some detail the story of elliot rogers
the incel um
and i was able to tell that story
because before he killed a bunch of
people and himself he left a 108 000
word memoir online which was you know
really a truly extraordinary document um
because he uh whilst being unbelievably
narcissistic is also incredibly honest
about his his his shortcomings and his
and his problems
and there you see and and i think you
know what i came to is is the most
dangerous people
are not only the ones who've been
humiliated again and again and again and
again but they're the the but they're
the they're the narcissists the
grandiose people who've been humiliated
again and again and again and again
because they feel entitled to a life up
here but what reality is giving them is
down here and down here and down here
you know for years
um
and you know especially if you're male
and you have a propensity to you know
solve status disputes with violence
that's a horrible cocktail male
grandiose and humiliated is really
really dangerous and you know i talk
about you know the example of the
unabomber is quite extraordinary this
this guy um went to harvard and had
we took part in these basically
humiliation experiments they were like a
government sponsored experiments i think
cia sponsored experiments to see the mk
ultra thing or is that a different guy i
think it was related to that um people
in the comments this is the sort of
thing that youtube excels at so we will
find the answer whoever knows the answer
about mk ultra and the unabomber please
link to a video in the comments yes yeah
so
so you so so they basically got a a a
group of people
including ted kaczynski and they said
you know you're going to do a scientific
experiment they didn't really tell them
what it is is as you know normal in
psychological experiments and they
basically had them write down all their
or their deep or their or their dreams
and hopes and ambitions lots of
confessions even about things like thumb
sucking and masturbation so all their
all their secrets all their hopes and
dreams and values and then they sat them
down in front of you know these bright
lights and basically mocked them mocked
these individuals and this happened
again and again and again
for years and you know kaczynski's
brother said you know we didn't know
what was going on but we saw the change
in him you know um
and you know what does the unin
unibomber stand for universities why
because
you know they were they were part of his
campaign of terror he would send you
know bombs to universities um
you know he he ended up with this kind
of mindset
the the the you know all these kind of
scientists who were kind of torturing
him when he was at harvard were
responsible for all the problems in the
world and he was you know the
grandiosity was there he was going to
lead this global revolution and you know
like elliot roger with his 108 000 word
memoir he had his i think thirty five
thousand word manifesto published in i
think it was the washington post uh you
know uh so so obviously a grandiose man
definitely you know
severely humiliated and you see the
consequences
grandiose humiliated and aggressive so
you've got the mail and mail so you've
got the dark triad but this is more like
the dangerous triad that's the three
that you need to make sure that you
don't have yeah it's um
it's interesting thinking about what
happens when people
lose status
that that it gets degraded over time
what about tall poppy syndrome and
people that that sort of have it and
then you have these huge falls because
there's a sense inside
the slow motion car crash everybody hate
follows some people on their social
media that the ones that you watch just
to sort of pity them because you you
enjoy watching how much they're sort of
wrecking everything and you know what
you mean chris
i'll go through your following if i need
to um but yeah everyone's got that and
the tall poppy syndrome must be a part
of this
yeah totally as i say you know if we
don't directly um you know relate to to
somebody and kind of really admire them
and want to be them we tend to you know
really become quite envious of them and
and so so yeah you know the tall poppy
syndrome has been found to be a
cross-cultural um uh
effect there was a great study that i
didn't put in the status game because it
was in my previous book i didn't want to
didn't want i would love to have cut and
paste it into this pollinated two books
yeah yeah but but it was done by the
psychologist in the university of
shenzhen
and um it was uh it was really clever so
they got these people and then and then
they you know to say you know we're
going to you're going to be taking part
in a neuroscientific experiment but
we're running a bit late and you know so
um why don't you go over there and play
this computer game and you know just
spend 10 minutes on there
so you go over and you play this
computer game and you go off the
computer game and you say well um you
know just just out of interest you were
kind of pretty mediocre you know all
these people over here did much better
than you and all those people over there
did much worse than you so that you so
you okay you sit down and then they put
these people in a brain scanner and they
and they show them i think images or
videos of having injections in their
face and what they were looking for were
um uh signals of empathy because as you
probably know you know when
when we um it's the i think tanya singer
i think that was the neuroscientist that
found this that when we empathize the
you know
not the same um
neural patterns but similar neural
patterns will be seen in the brain as if
we were actually getting that injection
in our face
so they they they took them and the
people that they saw were the people
from the waiting room who done either
better or worse at the game than them
and then afterwards they said to the
people you know um did you feel empathy
you know what did to think about those
images and they said oh it's terrible
the injections oh must have been awful
and they said did you feel empathy for
for them oh yes yes yes did you feel
empathy for all of them oh yes yes yes
but the brain scans gave the lie they
tended to only feel empathy for the
people who've done worse than them that
on the game and they didn't feel any
empathy for the people who did better
than them on the game so that shows you
you know it's just extraordinary
evidence for this you know this tall
poppy syndrome that people who we see as
higher status than us we you know we
don't feel empathy for them we don't
like them
another you know the study that i do
quoted in the status game shows that
peop you know when people reading about
somebody's successful and rich
their pain signals become more activated
or you know the the kind of the the
yeah the the pain signals become evident
and and then when when they read a story
that say of that same person being you
know suffering a fall pleasure systems
become activated so so so you know it's
in us it's the status game
mechanism
in our brain yeah it's it's how we
experience the world and it's
not a nice part of human nature but it
but it is an undeniable part of human
nature
thank you very much for tuning in if you
enjoyed that then press here for the
full unedited episode and don't forget
to subscribe makes me very happy indeed
peace
you